wir sind heute hier in wiener neustadt
am markt kommen wo wir zum einen hat das
neue das gebäude hinter mir übergeben
also denke ich ein ganz wichtiger
schritt auch für die weiterentwicklung
der infrastruktur und ein erster
wichtiger schritt auch wieder
zusammenführung des jagdkommandos hier
und ja es hat mich auch gefreut dass
neue mittlere scharfschützengewehr heute
zu übergeben auch ganz ganz wesentlich
für die auftragserfüllung für das
jagdkommandos aber auch insgesamt für
die infanterie truppe das heißt ein
guter tag für das österreichische
bundesheer und ein guter tag für das
jagd gemacht